[Music]
you're a canadian yes sir i don't say
that in an accusing cruel way i see it
in a very welcoming you are canadian
yeah uh and uh wonderful and and hockey
is so huge in canada this was the
greatest thing
yes and so
los angeles
the kings win the stanley cup yeah and i
don't know if you saw this we actually
watched on television the victory parade
for los angeles winning the stanley cup
this is real we didn't do anything to
this check this out there they are
they're on a bus they've got the stanley
cup
they're driving through the heart of
downtown l.a
and nobody gives a crap
look at that well
that's just preposterous
that's insane i mean i you know toronto
would be drinking and going toronto
toronto they would i mean first of all
everyone would lose their minds in
toronto well first of all i was at two
of those games at the playoffs games it
was so exciting the kings were brilliant
uh you know and and and you go to the
dressing room and
and you're everywhere you look there's a
toothless white man you know it's just
that
at first you think you're hosting the
country music awards
i'm telling you it was exciting my son
oliver and my son henry and i we all
were going crazy now here's a question
45 years or something well the times
that i have been in canada and toronto
vancouver everybody
i get the impression that everybody
plays hockey every single citizen in
canada is encouraged to play hockey
that's the impression you get were you a
hockey player i i we we did you know we
would freeze the backyard and i was the
youngest of five kids and i was expected
but really i was in my attic
weather-wise it's such a cuckoo day
i mean i was performing
an imaginary pause record yeah in my own
world but i mean i was i was like third
string zamboni operator
what about canadian football see that's
what i was a footballer i didn't realize
that football is quite popular canadian
football league is so great and this is
this is a slightly better joke when
there were nine teams now there are
eight teams right but what was great
about when there were nine teams there
were only nine teams in the league but
two were called rough riders
yeah two had the examples of the ottawa
rough riders and the saskatchewan rough
riders
true so sometimes you'd pass the tv and
you'd hear rough riders 28
rough riders seven
and as a little kid you're saying no i
feel bad for the rough riders but i'm
like real happy for the rough ride
that was fantastic uh now am i led to
believe that recently i read summer that
you went you were in washington dc uh at
the white house correspondents dinner is
that true i went to the white house
correspondents dinner i was the guest of
the vanity fair table and it was very
hip it was very hip but i i should not
really be allowed out publicly because i
make a series of faux pas wherever i go
and before the the the kind of event and
obama's there and jimmy kimmel was great
and it was a really exciting show
millions of people there and i see my
old friend richard kind you know richard
kind yes i do know richard kind yes and
a very funny actor and we had done film
clifford together and and and he's a
hilarious man and and i see it and we're
talking and i'm joking with them and
then there's a after party afterwards
and i see him standing there talking to
george clooney so i go up to this a
couple hours later i go up to him and i
put my arms around him and say oh
papa's gained a little weight and i
turned around and it's not richard kyne
it is david axelrod the chief of staff
of a
white house chief of staff
oh hi sir nice this
when he was 77 years old i was at this
hollywood party and and and i'd never
met him and he was my total idol frank
sinatra you met francis i remember frank
and he's standing beside a bar like this
perfect sinatra's like this with a drink
in his hand and i go up to him and i say
uh
mr santa hello um
my name's martin short and i just have
to tell you you have no idea you have no
concept of how
big a fan i am of yours and he looked at
me and said
i think i do
he said what are you drinking kid and i
would whatever you're drinking frank and
then he turned to the bartender and said
jack daniels and the bartender said
straight up or on the rocks but i was
nervous i thought he said straight up or
relaxed so i said i'll have it relaxed
and frank said he said straight up or on
the rock
i already i
i now had known frank 15 seconds and i
pissed him off
i thought soon he'd go for the gun
the sad albums anymore
so you know i just slinked off into the
night i'm glad you survived